[музика]
природа вона стала мовчазною жертвою
цієї війни Україна одна з
найзамінованіших країн світу мабуть
найзамінованіша збитки тільки від
підриву каховської гез сягає
147 млрд грн Україна втратила понад 14
кубкімт води цього обсягу достатньо щоб
два дні поїти водою весь світ загальна
сума збитків вона вже перевищує 2,2
трильн грн я вірю в те що ми можемо
довести ці всі злочини в міжнародних
судах і ми можемо довести ці збитки пане
міністр Ми сьогодні
зібрались поговорити про шкоду
завдану довкіллю війни Чи можете оцінити
якою є поточна оцінка цієї шкоди в
цифрах з перших днів повномасштабного
вторнення державно елогічна інспекція
обраховує всі збитки які рашисти
наносять нашому довкіллю використовуючи
сім нових методик на сьогоднішній день
маємо вже інформацію про задокументовані
більше ніж
2900 таких випадків знищення нашого
довкілля Фактично це злочини проти
довкілля е загальна сума збитків вона
вже перевищує 2,2 трилн грн найбільшим
випадком екоциду який вони зробили на
нашій території це був підрив каховської
ГС збитки тільки від підриву каховської
ГС затоплення територій е сягає
147 млрд грн на той момент коли вони
здійснили цей теракт е це було 10% від
цих збитків які були обраховані на той
момент Але я впевнений в тому що ми
будемо продовжувати цю роботу і всі ті
випадки які ще не обраховані вони будуть
відповідно додані в загальний кошик
збитків на жаль на
жалье руйнування і втрати вони не
зупинили сьогодні бо война війна триває
Але я впевнений в тому що та робота яка
робиться вона точно повинна дати змогу
зафіксувати всі випадки задокументувати
всі злочини тому що ми після нашої
Перемоги повинні Виставити окупанту
рахунок за кожний клаптик зруйнованої
Української Землі яка там зараз ситуація
е близ біля е каховської с в цьому
території е зараз вже пройшло майже
півроку які там зараз ви бачите наслідки
е коли рашисти Зробили цей теракт на
Каховський ГЕС ее найбільша втрата яка
фактично відбулася це те що ее річка
Дніпро і відповідно Україна втратила
понад 14 кубі кмт води це колосальний
обсяг води
яким просто для розуміння цього обсягу
достатньо щоб два дні поїти водою весь
світ це колосальні цифри колосальний
обсяг води до чого це призвело в першу
чергу це призвело до до руйнування
інфраструктур інфраструктурних об'єктів
для до руйнування життя
людей це призвело до затоплення великої
кількості лісів 50% із яких скоріш за
все вже вмеруть тому що вони були
затоплені дуже сильно пошкоджена була
територія деяких наших національних
парків відповідно рамсарських угідь але
ми розуміємо що 14 ку кмт води прісної
води Вони точно не пройшли непомітно
потрапивши в Чорне море відбулися
процеси опріснення е Які скоріш за все
самостійно вирівняються пізніше але це
це дуже серйозний вплив велика кількість
відходів потрапило в Чорне море була
інформація про те що більше 150 ТН
мастила потрапило у відповідно воду це
Колосальне забруднення яке в тому числі
спостерігали потім і на березі річки
Дніпро тому що нафтопродукти
нафтопродуктову плівку її просто
прибивали до берега відповідно її треба
було потім збирати е ми повинні сьогодні
пам'ятати що осушення дна Каховського
водосховища - це потенційні процеси
опустелювання і процеси
розвитку інвазивних видів рослин які
потенційно можуть з'явитися на дні
Каховського водосховища інвазивні види
вони є більш агресивними ніж ті види які
характерні відповідно вони будуть
захоплювати екосистему значно швидше для
цього щоб це не відбулося працівники
наших національних парків які знаходять
знаходять ться в безпосередній
близькості вони прове провели заходи із
залуження частини дна Каховського
водосховища фактично засадили його
різнотрав'ям для того щоб в першу чергу
не допустити інвазію в другу чергу для
того щоб зберегти чашу Каховського
водосховища щоб вона не руйнувалась без
води
е втрати насправді колосальні за моїм за
моїм проханням до нас прибула Місія юнеп
це спеціальна місія була організована
спеціально для обрахунку і фіксації
збитків внаслідок цього теракту
е це були представники більше 20
представників майже з 20 країн світу е
вони працювали кілька місяців наразі є
відповідний опублікований звіт е і ми
розуміємо що в цьому звіті не
відображено не відображені всі збитки
довкіллю тому що там ситуація вкрай
небезпечна е навіть
коли відповідні співробітники служби
надзвичайних ситуацій рятували Людей
просто рашисти продовжували гатити з
артилерії і відповідно навіть деякі
працівники національної поліції
державної служби надзвичайних ситуацій
були або травмовані або навіть загинули
тому у рашистів немає нічого Святого
вони не зупиняються є інформація про те
що в результаті підриву каховської ГЕС
навіть потенційно
зникли ендемічні види тварин Тобто Це ті
тваринки які жили в єдиному місці На
землі є такий маленький гризун ямуранчик
який жив тільки там в Херсонській
області більше в світі його не було
підрів каховської ГЕС потенційно знищив
цей ендемічний вид і фактично Планета
втратила ще один ще одного
представника фауни
в природі нічого не проходить безслідно
і втрата одного виду може призвести до
втрати багатьох інших видів як це вплине
далі вже на
розвиток екологічний розвиток і
відновлення екосистем покаже час але
Наша задача сьогодні це Не залишити без
уваги жодний випадок знищення нашого
довкілля та дати світові
інструменти
мати змогу обраховувати ці збитки
внаслідок війни тому що якщо ми сьогодні
залишимо це без
уваги
ми не зможемо зробити так щоб кожен
майбутній агресор кожна майбутня війна
вона обраховувалася не тільки у вартості
зброї і не тільки у вартості воєнних
дій кожен наступний агресор у будь-якому
куточку світі світу Він повинен розуміти
що війна - це дорого і дорого тому що
довкілля теж має свою ціну зараз ви
сказали що Каховська ГЕС і вся ця
територія зараз знаходиться в зоні
бойових дій але які є плани відновити ці
цій цю екологію після того як
можна і скільки це буде кошту Насправді
немає зараз достоменних підрахунків
скільки буде коштувати відновити цю
територію є території які навіть за
будь-які кошти світу ми не відновимо Я
сьогодні Кажу про водноболотні угіддя
рамсарські угіддя частину національних
парків якій формувала
природа багато-багато років а рашисти
сьогодні або гатять з артилерії або
запускають ракети або знищують танками
ці цінні території тому сказати що треба
для того щоб його відновити треба просто
скоі за все цій природі не заважати Ми
повинні з вами пам'ятати що величезна
кількість території нашої країни
сьогодні замінована Україна одна з
найзамінованіших країн світу мабуть
найзамінованіша близько 30% території
країни є потенційно
замінованою на розмінування піде дуже
багато років і відновлювати довкілля ми
можемо тільки після того як зможемо
забезпечити безпеку тих людей які це
будуть робити або да дати природі тишу
щоб вона змогла
самовідновитися Я впевнений в тому що ми
можемо відновити наші ліси ми можемо
посадити нові саджанці нові сіянці Але
ми не прискоримо час тому що той ліс
Який ріс десятки років він не виросте за
один день ми це не прискоримо тому
будемо робити все можливе але зараз
вкрай важливо те щоб наші збройні сили
все-таки відкинули орків до
конституційних кордонів нашої країни
вигнали їх за
кордони І після того ми вже будемо
говорити про дообрахування тих тих
збитків які ми ще не дообрахували і Далі
будемо думати як виходити ситуація
відновлення нашої живої природи
хоча наприклад там випадки з мертвими
дельфінами А у нас їх їх є зафіксованих
вже близько тисячі тільки офіційно хоча
за неофіційними даними таких випадків
може бути десятки тисяч Ми сьогодні
говоримо з партнерами про потенційне
будівництво реабілітаційного центру для
дельфінів або в Одеській або в
Херсонській області Тобто там де це буде
Можливо тому що ми розуміємо що природа
вона стала мовчазною жертвою цієї війни
і ми
повинні сьогодні все-таки їй допомогти
реабілітуючи тварин або відновлюючи
екосистеми сама ГЕС буде відновлена чи
ні дивіться питання дуже дискусійне
насправді і я можу вам сказати одне що в
першу чергу
важливо забезпечити там безпеку І
взагалі можливість щось зробити У мене
наприклад немає на сьогоднішній день
інформації взагалі щодо конкретного
пошкодження тобто е що саме було
пошкоджено як пошкоджено чи можливо її
відновити в тому вигляді в якому вона є
тому я впевнений що треба залишити час
експертам для того щоб це питання дуже
детально по вивчити давайте про злочини
Генпрокуратура ее повідомила що від
зафіксувала більш 200 е воєнних злочинів
проти до проти довкілля
А як ви оцінюєте що
злочин А що може бути супутня втра
втрата дивіться ми на сьогоднішній день
дуже плідно працюємо з офісом
Генерального прокурора нещодавно ми
навіть провели міжнародний спільний
форум United for Justice United for
Nature Ми сьогодні шукаємо певні шляхи
кооперації тому що екологічна інспекція
може зафіксувати злочини ті майже
2 900 злочинів проти довкілля які за
увала
екоінспекція вони так чи інакше
потрапляють до Генеральної прокуратури
де вони вже формують кримінальні справи
е важливо що рік тому Генеральний
прокурор Андрій
Костін анонсував відкриття офіса
прокурора міжнародного кримінального
суду в Україні Це допоможе нашим
правникам прокурорам правильно
сформувати ті справи які спочатку
повинні від вистояти в наших судах а
потім вже ее бути захищеними в
міжнародному кримінальному суді це
важливо в першу чергу Е для того щоб
весь світ визнав ті збитки які сьогодні
рашисти наносять в тому числі нашим
екосистемам Я хочу нагадати що було
започатковано міжнародний реєстр
збитків невід'ємною складовою цього
реєстру є
е ті злочини проти довкілля які ми
сьогодні фіксуємо
я вірю в те що використовуючи сьогодні
нові методи і фактично роблячи це
спільно з офісом Генерального прокурора
вперше в історії людства фіксацію
збитків довкілля внаслідок війни
використовуючи
вперше методики оцінки збитків внаслідок
війни ми започаткуємо той процес
який у будь-якому випадку дасть нам
змогу відшкодувати втрати наших
екосистем а Але для того щоб це
вважалось злочином Там же ще є інші інша
критерія те що це
навмисний навмисне пошкодження довкілля
як ви це робите е дуже гарне питання але
можу сказати вам одне що Наша задача -
це виконати ті завдання які сьогодні
перед нами стоять і відповідно вже
передати офісу Генерального прокурора
тому що юристи і правники я вони повинні
зробити свою роботу але ми розуміємо що
сьогодні вкрай важливо вже зробити
кілька пілотних таких кримінальних справ
пройти через суд в тому числі через
міжнародний кримінальний суд для того
щоб зрозуміти де могли бути помилки під
час документування під час збирання
доказів під час обрахунку під час
формування тих самих справ які
відправляються в суд і Я впевнений в
тому що відповідь на ваше запитання воно
буде буде після того як такі кілька
кейсів стануть реальністю зараз
досвіда з такими випадками ще немає в
міжнародних судах яке у вас є очікування
який може бути результат я вірю в те що
ми можемо довести ці всі злочини в
міжнародних судах і ми можемо довести ці
збитки на конференції United for Justice
United for Nature яка
була в цьому році в Києві яку До речі
відвідало велика кількість міністрів
довкілля з інших
країн ми презентували драфт довкілвої
декларації це декларація про готовність
започаткувати платформу яка об'єднає всі
країни які бажають до неї доєднатися і
не тільки на політичному рівні на
експертному на науковому на інших рівнях
ми вже не сумніваємося і весь світ не
сумнівається хто є насправді агресором
хто прийшов на чужу землю хто
намагається нищити все українське
це Путін який своїми злочинними наказами
сьогодні руйнує все включаючи наше
довкілля
тому вкрай важливо що ми не по винні вже
сьогодні це доказувати але ми повинні
сьогодні провести верифікацію експертну
верифікацію отримати політичне схвалення
доєднати якомога більше країн світу до
цього процесу і прийняти спільне
виважене рішення і вже далі проводити
відповідну адвокацію та стягування
відповідних
збитків якщо ми бачимо на те що
відбувається зараз в цієї війни і на цю
кількість злочин
які зараз
відбуваються Наскільки ці справи про
злочини проти довкілля важливий чи на
фоні смерті людей вважається це менш
значучим Справа в тому що ми повинні
зважати на всі аспекти і всі наслідки
цієї війни ще раз підкреслюю збитки
довкіллю вони обраховуються
вперше якщо казати про фіксацію взагалі
оцих злочинів проти довкілля то їх
вартість вона в деяких
випадках може бути або дорівнювати або
навіть перевищувати ті збитки які
задаються в інфраструктурі я з вами
повністю погоджую що життя людей це
вкрай важливо це це перше пер ше що на
що треба зважати і чим повинні займатися
там прокуратура органи Генерального
прокурора
але ще раз
кажу важливо зафіксувати абсолютно всі
злочини І абсолютно всі збитки
комплексно оцінюючи всі ці збитки ми
робимо крок для запобігання майбутнім
війнам або збройним конфліктам у
будь-якій точці світу пане міністр
Дякуємо за інтерв'ю
дякую
вам